وقد نقلت وكلته رويترز الانباء عن الجيش
الكوري الجنوبيه نواشنطن ارسلت قاضي فاتن
استراتيجيه للمشاركه في المناورات الجويه
المشتركه
الجنوبي تحرقه مقاتله كوريا الجنوبيه من
طراز اف 35 اي وطائرات امريكيه من طراز اف
16 في تشكيل جوي قبله الساحل الشرقي لشبه
الجزيره الكوريه
الجنوبيه
لكوريا واجره القوات الامريكيه واليابانيه
منورات مماثله
وفي تصريحه جديد لرئيس الوزراء الياباني
هوميو كشيده قال ان بلاده ستعمل على تعزيز
سياسه الدفاع في ظل التوتر العالي للامن
الاقليم في المنطقه
الاسيويه مرحبا دكتور
يعني هذا هذه تجارب المتكرره لكوريا
الشماليه واعلان زعيم الكوري بانه سيستخدم
اسلحه النوويه للرد على اي تهديدات
ما تفسيره الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
لتوقيتها الان علما بان كوريا اجرد سابقا
كوريا
صواريخ اخرى
نور
كويسيتها المتعلقه باطلاق الصواريخ
البالستيه العابره للقارات وكذلك صواريخ
اخرى متوسطه وقصيره المدى في المنطقه
لانهم يريدون ان يكون هناك هذه الاختبارات
لانها لديها هناك بعض الاهداف اذا يريدون
المحافظه على نظامهم وكذلك يسعون للحصول
على
وضعهم المرتبط
وتواجد اسلحه نوويه لديهم الاعتراف من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك ردت فعل
تتعلق بشان كون الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه يزيدون من وتيره ونطاق التمارين
العسكريه التي ينظر اليها على انها تشكل
تهديدا بالنسبه لكوريا
مع اليابان والولايات المتحده الامري كيا
اذا الروسيا تدعم الان القضيه كوريا
الشماليه وتعلن ان هناك مصالح طبعا ذات
مصداقيه وكذلك هناك مباحث قلق مشروع كما
تقول روسيا وهذا يعزز موقف كوريا الشماليه
خصوصا بعد الاجتماع الذي جرى ما بينغ
والولايات المتحده
بينغا وهذا كذلك سيؤثر على موقع وموقف
كوريا الشماليه الصين الاسبوع الماضي قامت
بالدعم الموقف
الكوري الكوري الشمالي لكن بعد تخفيف
مستوى التوتر الموجود
في الوضع الذي يجري في كوريا الشماليه
ربما الاستراتيجيه قد تتغير لابد ان لا
ننساه تط الفتره الاخيره التي جرت في
الاجتماعات الاخيره على هامشي القمه والتي
تؤدي الى اتساق متزايده بين كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان والولايات المتحده مما
يجعل الوضع اكثر الصعوبه وربما قد يؤدي
الى اللحيه بالنسبه
لحوار مع كوريا الشماليه وان كانت قنوات
الاتصال غير مفتوحه كيف نفهم هذا التصريح
اوف كويس
جاهزه جاهزه بالنسبه للحوار لكن هذا
الحوار بمقد يختلف عن ما كان عليه الوضع
خلال اذارتي
اذا كان هناك عدد من الانجازات
والاختراقات التي جرت في ذلك الوقت
في نهايه المطاف الى تفكيك البرنامج
قد و بشكل متزايد بسبب حاله الاستقطاب
الدوليه التي نشهدها في المنطقه اذا الوضع
في شبه جزيره الكوريه وضعها صعب خصوصا في
وجود تنافس ما بين الصين والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الاستاذ بجامعه بولونيا
والخبير في الشؤون الصينيه والاسيويه شكرا
لك